I got to tell you I've made I don't know
how many movies 30 40 movies in my
career and that was the first time that
happened Jennifer Lopez has been a
household name for over 20 years but
even a superstar like her still has
career firsts the triple threat opened
up to ET about all the awards season but
she's getting for her drama hustlers
which featured an all-female cast and
crew that that makes it a little bit
sweeter right that it was all women
producers and it's a woman director at a
woman writer and all women cast and and
a woman you know I mean we really went
deep and and you don't see that I got to
tell you I've made I don't know how many
movies 30 40 movies in my career and it
was the first time that happened that
was the first time so it was a pretty
special kind of unicorn event and it's
great that it's being received in the
way it is because they're not just
seeing that it's like we can make a good
movie but also they make a successful
movie that makes money that matters in
this business so that was an amazing
thing to be part of I'd be lying if I
didn't say I was thrilled and excited
and overwhelmed and didn't expect it but
I'm so happy it's happening you know
kayla was a glitzy vision in a yellow
Reem Acra gown at the 11th annual
governors awards but she's not the only
one who gets to dress up she told us her
kids are so excited to rock costumes on
Halloween I was just on the phone my
daughter in the car on the way here and
she's like scared you're gonna be a Care
Bear
she's gonna be a very my son
decided he's like in between might be a
skeleton eating I don't know something
from a game I'm sure and get this JLo is
getting a total kick out of all the
people dressing up as her in that iconic
green Versace dress I already saw some
which was so funny on Instagram I was
like okay here we go
having that moment a few weeks ago I
think put it back in people's mind that
in Milan but I don't know I don't know
if you're gonna even have time
unfortunately to dress up I leave here
go right back to work
thank you thank you also that
[Music]